[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe mir gedacht, es wird mal wieder Zeit für Pralinen.
Also stelle ich heute drei unterschiedliche Pralinen her
und zwar mit weißen, Vollmilch-
und Zartbitterschokoladenhohlkörpern.
Die kennt ihr auch bereits.
Also, falls ihr Pralinen machen wollt,
gibt es auf meinem Kanal auch schon verschiedene Rezepte,
mal mit Hohlkörper, mal ohne.
Aber ich muss halt echt sagen,
so als Geschenkidee zu Weihnachten
oder einfach mal so
sind die halt echt auch superschnell gemacht.
Also recht schnell.
Es ist trotzdem noch relativ viel Arbeit.
Aber gerade so mit Hohlkörpern hat man eben
auch gleich eine gleichmäßige Form
und kann im Prinzip mit dem Geschmack
herumexperimentieren, wie man möchte.
Ich starte jetzt direkt mal
mit den weißen Schokoladenhohlkörpern
und werde jetzt hier eine
– ja, so wie eine Bounty-Praline machen,
also Schokolade, Zartbitterschokolade, Kokos
und Tonka mache ich jetzt noch mit rein
so für den Sally-Touch.
Und ich glaube, die wird ziemlich lecker.
Für die Füllung verwende ich
Sahne,
Kokosraspeln,
Zartbitterschokolade,
etwas Tonka Wonka
– ihr könnt aber auch eine Tonkabohne reiben –
und, wie gesagt, hier die Hohlkörper.
Das sind die weißen.
Die genaue Mengenangabe schreibe ich euch
dann in die App beziehungsweise in den Blog.
Denn ich muss sagen,
ich teste das ja heute auch zum ersten Mal
und ich möchte dann die Menge so angeben,
dass es exakt in diese 63 Hohlkörper passt,
also dass ihr nichts zu viel habt, aber auch nicht zu wenig.
Deswegen, falls hier was nicht stimmt,
korrigiere ich noch die Menge.
Was ich jetzt machen werde, ist, die Sahne
mit den Kokosflocken zu vermischen und zu mixen,
damit die ein bisschen zerkleinert werden.
Müsst ihr nicht machen, ihr könnt sie auch so lassen,
aber ich hätte sie gern zerkleinert.
Daher alles hier rein.
Ihr könnt hier auch einen Kokoslikör noch zufügen,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Dann fein pürieren.
Zack.
Oh!
Riecht lecker.
Jetzt kommt das Ganze in den Topf
und wird kurz aufgekocht,
damit sie warm ist und ich darin
die Schokolade schmelzen kann.
[Musik]
Dann kommt hier die Schokolade rein,
darf mit geschmolzen werden.
Und dafür jetzt den Herd ausschalten,
also wirklich nur noch in dieser warmen Masse
sozusagen schmelzen.
Okay. Jetzt sieht es gerade echt aus wie so ein
– ih, wie so ein Babybrei.
Von früher kenne ich die noch,
diese, die man so angemischt hat.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh! Aber die habe ich gern gegessen.
[Musik]
Das sieht jetzt richtig gut aus!
Jetzt kommt hier noch Tonka mit rein.
Müsst ihr nicht, könnt ihr machen.
Ihr könnt auch Vanille nehmen, passt auch gut zu Kokos.
[Musik]
Jetzt könnt ihr diese Masse im Prinzip mit Spritzbeuteln
oder auch mit einer Dosierflasche
einfach in die Pralinenhohlkörper füllen.
Das wäre jetzt natürlich
– wenn das hier reinpasst,
wäre das schon schön,
so richtig perfekt.
Fast. Okay.
Ist okay.
Oh!
Eins, zwei, drei.
Tschu!
Ha!
Das kann ich ja dann noch mal auffüllen.
Jetzt natürlich darauf achten,
dass es jetzt nicht kochend heiß ist,
wenn es in die Hohlkörper kommt,
sondern so ein bisschen
– lauwarm ist okay.
Dann könnt ihr jetzt die Hohlkörper füllen
und zwar bis fast unter den Rand.
Also so ein bisschen müsst ihr übrig lassen.
Denn der Hohlkörper
– das ist ja praktisch Schokolade außenrum –
wird dann oben verschlossen mit Schokolade.
Also bei den weißen verschließe ich es
auch mit der weißen Schokolade.
Deswegen so ein bisschen weniger,
damit das später auch eine schöne Kugel wird.
[Musik]
Die Hohlkörper sind jetzt gefüllt.
Und die kann ich jetzt hier verschließen
ganz einfach mit dem Karton.
Das ist auch echt megapraktisch, muss ich sagen,
weil ich so viele verschiedene Pralinen machen kann.
Und die kann ich jetzt ins Gefrierfach stellen,
dass die Füllung fest wird.
Ich kann sie auch schön stapeln
und sie sind einfach aufgeräumt.
Und von der Menge her von der Füllung muss ich sagen,
ich habe jetzt hier ungefähr noch so viel übrig.
Ich würde es jetzt einfach für euch genau so angeben.
Dann habt ihr halt ein bisschen was übrig,
könnt das aber auch zum Beispiel als Brotaufstrich benutzen
oder als Tortenfüllung oder was auch immer.
Also ich lasse die Menge so.
Jetzt packe ich die weißen Hohlkörper direkt voll
in den Gefrierschrank und mache weiter mit Version zwei.
Das sind nämlich die Vollmilchhohlkörper.
Wow! Vollmilchhohlkörper.
Das würde ich mal gern bei
– wie heißt das Spiel mit den Strichen?
Wie heißt das?
>> JOSH: Hangman.
>> SALLY: Galgenmännchen!
>> JOSH: Galgenmännchen.
>> SALLY: Das mache ich mal.
Jetzt verwende ich die Vollmilchschokoladenhohlkörper.
Und dafür mache ich eine Haselnussfüllung.
Und auf meinem Kanal gibt es schon ein Rezept
und zwar eine Haselnuss-Praliné.
Das ist so eine richtig leckere Füllung,
die ich damals verwendet habe für das Paris Brest Dessert.
Paris Brest Dessert?
Ach, mein Französisch ist eingerostet!
Egal.
Jedenfalls ist das praktisch so eine Nuss-Nougat-Masse.
Und die habe ich jetzt hier.
Die müsst ihr halt dann noch zubereiten.
Das könnt ihr im alten Video nachschauen.
Ich habe sie nämlich gut aufgehoben bis jetzt.
Dann etwas Sahne,
Vollmilchschokolade
und Zimt.
Denn ich mache jetzt Zimt-Haselnuss.
Und hierfür gebe ich jetzt auch die Sahne in den Topf,
lasse sie kurz aufkochen.
[Musik]
Dann den Herd ausschalten,
die Schokolade einrühren und schmelzen lassen.
[Musik]
Dann kommt hier die Praliné-Füllung rein.
Da kann es sein, dass sich da das Fett absetzt,
wenn ihr die auch gelagert habt.
Das ist aber gar nicht schlimm.
Ihr verrührt sie einfach wieder
und dann wird sie wieder schön homogen.
Und mit Zimt verfeinern.
Und einfach cremig rühren.
Und das auch wieder lauwarm abkühlen lassen
und dann die Hohlkörper füllen.
Was ich jetzt hier auch machen werde:
Ich habe die Hohlkörper einfach im Gefrierfach,
damit die schon mal kalt sind.
Und wenn diese Masse dann lauwarm ist,
also nicht mehr zu heiß, kann ich es wieder befüllen.
[Musik]
Das sieht schon lecker aus!
Was ihr hier auch machen könnt,
um das Ganze schneller abkühlen zu lassen:
Verschließt einfach die Flasche
und haltet sie kurz unter kaltes Wasser.
Und dann ist sie auch schnell lauwarm.
[Musik]
Pralinenfüllung Nummer drei besteht aus
Sahne,
Erdnussmus,
Vollmilchschokolade,
und Erdnüssen.
Die sind gesalzen.
Und hier habe ich ein Erdnussmus und keine Erdnussbutter,
weil das einfach reine Erdnüsse sind, die zerkleinert wurden.
Und eben bei Erdnussbutter hat man eben
noch andere Zutaten oft mit drin wie Zucker und Palmfett.
Und so habe ich einfach die reinen Erdnüsse.
Hier jetzt auch wieder erst die Sahne kochen
und dann die Schokolade darin schmelzen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt die Schokolade reinrühren.
Ups!
Upsi!
Oh, ich habe ihn gerade so schön abgeputzt!
[Musik]
Und hier gebe ich jetzt das Erdnussmus mit rein.
Uh! Mandelmus wäre auch leckerschmecker,
wenn man dann noch so Bittermandelöl mit reingibt,
so alla Amaretto.
Guckt einmal!
Und die Erdnüsse lasse ich jetzt mal noch im Ganzen.
Die kommen dann nämlich so direkt mit reingesteckt,
so als volle Erdnuss.
Und hier lasse ich jetzt auch
die Masse ganz kurz lauwarm abkühlen,
fülle es in die Flasche und dann fülle ich die Hohlkörper damit.
[Musik]
Und einfüllen.
Ich sollt euch vielleicht noch einen Tipp geben.
Bei mir war es jetzt nämlich auch der Fall,
dass die Düse hier vorne verstopft war,
weil das Erdnussmus
– da setzt sich ja oft das Fett ab.
Und am besten püriert ihr alles
vorher kurz mit dem Pürierstab,
damit alles homogen ist,
falls wirklich was nicht gut durchgerührt ist,
damit ihr alles schön einfüllen könnt.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Wenn die Erdnüsse nicht zu groß sind,
könnt ihr die sogar
direkt hier mit drinnen platzieren.
Oh, die war zu groß.
[Musik]
Am einfachsten ist es übrigens, wenn ihr die Hohlkörper
zuerst mit den ganzen Erdnüssen befüllt
und dann einfach mit der Pralinenmasse auffüllt.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich alle drei Sorten fertig gefüllt.
Die sind jetzt im Tiefkühlfach,
dürfen da schön fest werden.
Und dann brauche ich für jede Sorte,
also weiß, Vollmilch und Zartbitter,
einfach eine kleine Menge an Kuvertüre
zum Verschließen der Löcher.
Und die kann ich jetzt schon mal temperieren,
also schmelzen.
Das heißt, zwei Drittel davon
über einem warmen Wasserbad erwärmen
und dann das restliche Drittel einfüllen.
Und dann ist die Masse auch schon fertig.
Das bereite ich jetzt kurz vor,
fülle das aber, glaube ich, in Spritzbeutel wahrscheinlich
und kann dann die Pralinen damit abschließen.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon weiße Schokolade geschmolzen
zum Temperieren.
Also es muss halt einfach
auf die richtige Temperatur kommen.
Da gebe ich jetzt das restliche Drittel dazu.
Das kann jetzt hier schön schmelzen
und kühlt dann auch gut ab.
Ich bereite direkt alle vor,
also auch Vollmilch und Zartbitter.
Dann kann ich nämlich direkt nacheinander alles abarbeiten.
Und wenn ihr viele Pralinen machen wollt,
dann ist es so eigentlich auch immer die beste Methode.
Also erst mal alle füllen, dann alle verschließen
und zum Schluss alle dekorieren.
Dann hat man so jeden Arbeitsschritt nacheinander.
Und ich weiß noch, ich habe mal vor
– wann war das? Es muss 2013 gewesen sein.
Da habe ich mal 5.000 Pralinen gemacht
für den Weihnachtsmarkt hier in Kirrlach.
Da hat mir damals die Andrea geholfen
und da haben wir echt 5.000 Pralinen gerollt.
Also das war wirklich krass.
In der Wohnung damals noch.
Und wir konnten einfach nicht aufhören.
Immer noch eine, noch eine, komm, noch ein Päckchen.
Und dann, wow, hatten wir echt so viele.
So. Wenn das dann geschmolzen ist, sieht es so aus.
Und bei Kuvertüre muss man echt sagen,
also ich habe jetzt echt die Erfahrung gemacht
– ich habe oft auch Kuvertüre aus dem Supermarkt gekauft,
diese Blockkuvertüre, die es gibt.
Und jetzt habe ich momentan so Kuvertürechips
und teste die einfach gerade.
Und es wirklich so:
Wenn man diese Zwei-Drittel-ein-Drittel-Methode macht,
diese Impfmethode, um praktisch die Schokolade
auf die perfekte Temperatur zu bekommen,
passiert es manchmal trotzdem,
dass die Schokolade aus dem Supermarkt
einen Grauschleier bekommt.
Und jetzt habe ich eine hochwertigere Schokolade
mit mehr Kakaobutter drin
und die hat bisher keinen Grauschleier bekommen.
Also es kommt echt auf die Qualität an.
Hier nehme ich jetzt einen Minispritzbeutel,
stelle den einfach in so ein Glas.
Dann kann ich hier was reinfüllen
und damit gleich die Pralinen verschließen.
Noch schnell Vollmilch vorbereiten.
[Musik]
Und hier ist jetzt einfach nur wichtig,
dass die Füllung schon fest ist.
Dann könnt ihr mit einer Schere die Spitze wegschneiden,
eine schöne kleine Spitze.
Und die auch am besten direkt immer wegschmeißen,
damit die nirgends landet.
Und jetzt hier oben verschließen und wieder kaltstellen.
[Musik]
Den Spritzbeutel wasche ich kurz aus
und benutze den einfach für die anderen auch weiter.
Und diese Schokolade hebe ich mir noch auf.
Die brauche ich noch.
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Hast du das gemacht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Oder sind die gekauft?
>> SALLY: Nein, habe ich gemacht.
Schokohohlkörper gekauft und den Rest selbst gemacht.
Gefällt es dir?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
Und jetzt noch Zartbitter.
[Musik]
Jetzt werden die Pralinen fertig dekoriert.
Wie gesagt, jetzt sind sie auch schön fest.
Ihr nehmt euch einfach von der übrigen Schokolade,
von der Kuvertüre ein bisschen was in die Hand.
Eine Praline
– ich habe jetzt auch Handschuhe an,
damit ich das nicht auf den Händen alles habe.
Jetzt hier in Kokosraspeln wälzen.
Das ist die Bounty.
Es wäre auch schön, muss ich sagen, optisch,
wenn das jetzt außen Schoko, also dunkel wäre.
Denn ich bin sehr am
Hinundherüberlegen.
Weil eigentlich würde hier jetzt auch Zartbitter passen.
Weil Bounty ist nämlich Zartbitter außen.
Und hier, wenn man jetzt hier eine Hilfe hat,
finde ich es ganz gut,
also, wenn einer dann so das Rollen übernimmt,
der andere dann
diese Trockenmasse übernimmt.
[Musik]
Also am besten geht es natürlich
mit einer Assistentin an eurer Seite.
Ich muss nur leider sagen,
die beste Assistentin, die habe ich schon,
die ist bei mir in der Küche.
Aber ihr findet bestimmt auch jemanden, der euch hilft.
Denn es ist echt gut, wenn praktisch einer
den Part hier übernimmt mit der Schokolade
und der andere dann das Ummanteln.
[Musik]
So.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch ein paar mit dunkler Schokolade.
Okay. Kann es weitergehen?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Wenn ihr mit Kindern backt
beziehungsweise Pralinen macht,
solltet ihr auf jeden Fall den Schokoladenverschleiß
mit reinrechnen.
So 20%.
>> SAMIRA: 80.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Dann sind die ersten Pralinen
jetzt gleich schon fertig.
Für die nächste Variante, für die Vollmilch
werde ich natürlich die Vollmilchschokolade vorbereiten
und werde dann gehackte Haselnüsse,
die bereits geröstet sind, mit Zimt vermahlen.
Und die werden wir dann in Zimt-Haselnuss tauchen
und darin wälzen.
>> SAMIRA: Oh, lecker!
Das erinnert mich an ein Eis.
>> SALLY: An so Tartufo, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, oder Magnum.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SAMIRA: Weil das ist ja auch mit Haselnuss.
>> SALLY: Und die erinnern auch so ein bisschen an Rocher.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich habe jetzt hier die Haselnüsse und den Zimt.
Ich werde das jetzt ein bisschen nur zerkleinern,
also tatsächlich schon ein bisschen grobb lassen.
Grobb? Grob.
>> SAMIRA: Grob.
>> SALLY: Grob.
Und du kannst dir jetzt ein bisschen Schokolade
in die Handfläche geben
und ganz vorsichtig dann praktisch massieren,
damit die Praline mit der Schokolade umhüllt ist.
Und dann ist das gleich hier bereit.
[Musik]
Die Erdnuss-Zartbitterpralinen machen wir jetzt so:
Samira ummantelt sie mit der Schokolade
und ich nehme noch Erdnusskrokant für hier obendrauf.
Wenn ihr kein Erdnusskrokant habt,
– das gibt es in der Backabteilung –
könnt ihr auch einfach gehackte Erdnüsse noch mal nehmen,
diese salzigen.
Vielleicht nehme ich einfach
– ja, ich glaube, ein paar mache ich so mit Krokant
und ein paar mit Erdnüssen.
>> SAMIRA: Aber Krokant ist doch einfach zu machen, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Das ist halt so süßer, das andere wäre halt salziger.
Dann hat man noch mal so diesen salzigen Geschmack
auf der Praline, was ich, glaube ich, am besten finde.
[Musik]
Die Pralinen sind jetzt fertig und dürfen verkostet werden.
Da ist er wieder, unser Profiverkoster,
>> MURAT: Ja, Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Murat.
>> MURAT: Endlich mal wieder Zeit gefunden.
Obwohl es draußen kalt ist,
habe ich wirklich saumäßig viel auf der Baustelle zu tun.
Und...
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und da waren die Typen, die...
Was heißt die Typen?
Die Firma, die Trockenwände reinmacht,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: ja,
die gibt es nicht mehr.
>> SALLY: Die kommen nicht mehr.
>> MURAT: Die kommen nicht mehr.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt musst du es machen.
>> MURAT: Ja, jetzt muss ich es mit dem Güni alleine machen.
>> SALLY: Kriegt ihr das hin?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Aber wir müssen.
>> SALLY: Soll ich euch helfen? Ich kann gut verspachteln,
>> MURAT: Ja, ich merke gerade, du kannst...
>> SALLY: verputzen,
>> MURAT: Verputzen kann ich auch sehr gut.
>> SALLY: 90°-Winkel. Ich nehme die Tortenwaage mit.
>> MURAT: Im Verputzen bin ich der Beste.
Das da hier
– du machst eigentlich jedes Jahr Pralinen, gell?
>> SALLY: Schon. Ja.
>> MURAT: Kannst du dich noch erinnern...
>> SALLY: Baust du jetzt gerade Druck auf,
dass ich nächstes Jahr wieder Pralinen machen soll?
>> MURAT: Nee, ich sage nur:
Kannst du dich noch erinnern, wo wir mal
– ich glaube, es waren 2.000 oder 4.000...
>> SALLY: 5.000.
>> MURAT: 5.000 Pralinen haben wir mal gemacht.
Das war
vor vier Jahren, glaube ich, auf dem Weih-
>> SALLY: Nee, länger. Das war 2013.
>> MURAT: 2013?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Das war vor fünf Jahren.
Nee, vor sieben. O mein Gott!
Okay.
>> SALLY: Mathe ist nicht dein...
>> MURAT: Vor sieben Jahren haben wir mal 5.000 Pralinen
für den Weihnachtsmarkt gemacht.
Und Pralinen sind nicht
– also richtig gut gemachte Pralinen sind nicht günstig,
muss man ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja, vor allem, die sind ja auch handgemacht.
Und viele Konditoreien, die das anbieten,
da kostet wirklich eine Praline einen Euro oder mehr.
>> MURAT: Und
>> SALLY: Das finde ich aber auch okay.
>> MURAT: es ist es wert. Es ist es wirklich wert.
>> SALLY: Eben.
>> MURAT: Weil ihr müsst auch verstehen, dass,
wenn man in einer Konditorei solche Sachen macht,
Konditoren nehmen meistens auch
eine sehr, sehr hochwertige Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und bei Macarons sind die Menschen bereit,
das zu bezahlen, weil es so Trend-Food geworden ist,
und bei Pralinen, denke ich mir so,
muss man es halt eigentlich erst recht bezahlen,
weil es wirklich viel Handarbeit ist.
Magst du eigentlich wissen, was ich hier gebacken habe?
>> MURAT: Pralinen.
>> SALLY: Gemacht, nicht gebacken, zubereitet habe.
Das sind so Bounty-Geschmack.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Die sind so
>> MURAT: Giotto?
>> SALLY: Ferrero, Giotto, Raffaello
– nicht Raffaello, Ferrero, Giotto, genau, Rocher.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
>> SALLY: Und die sind Erdnuss.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Ich probiere jetzt mich durch, okay?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay. Also...
>> SALLY: Genau.
Ich will auch.
Und bei uns gibt es eine Abbeißpflicht
bei Pralinen und Plätzchen.
Darf ich auch?
Ich will nicht von...
Ja.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Das war jetzt was?
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: So Richtung Bounty.
>> MURAT: Cool.
>> SALLY: Und vor allem die Füllung,
die ist so cremig.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Also nach den Einfrieren taut sie auch wieder auf.
Wenn man es im Kühlschrank hat,
dann hat man so eine cremige Füllung.
Das ist das Gleiche nur mit weißer Schokolade.
>> MURAT: Ja, das schmeckt genau gleich
nur mit weißer Schokolade.
Das ist mir sofort aufgefallen.
So.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Und die war echt gut.
Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und was ihr hier machen könnt
– oh, zeig das mal! Zeig das mal!
Den Anbiss, guckt mal, wie cremig!
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und was ich halt...
>> MURAT: Aber mit Giotto hat das nichts zu tun,
sage ich dir gleich, jetzt ganz ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Nee, aber von der Optik her.
>> MURAT: Von der Optik her, ja.
>> SALLY: Und genau, was ich sagen will:
Man kann ja das dann schön bunt mischen,
in so ein Tütchen verpacken, was Nettes dranschreiben.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder in eine Tasse verpacken.
>> MURAT: Und da "Komplett handgemacht" draufschreiben.
Auf das bin ich auch gespannt.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh! Die ist richtig cremig geworden. Boah!
>> MURAT: Ich glaube, ich habe meinen Favoriten.
>> SALLY: Ich wusste es.
>> MURAT: Ja?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Und weißt du warum?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> MURAT: Hier außenrum hast du
eine Zartbitterschokolade genommen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und die Zartbitterschokolade
macht das Ding nicht ganz so süß.
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> MURAT: Und das ist das Coole daran.
>> SALLY: Halt!
Ich will auch probieren.
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was ich sagen muss:
Ich bin ja Zartbitterfan.
Also mein Favorit ist wirklich immer Zartbitter,
selbst wenn ich jetzt
– ich wollte halt für euch drei verschiedene machen.
Aber ihr könnt ja auch sagen
– wenn ihr zum Beispiel
die mit Haselnuss nicht so süß haben wollt,
nehmt einfach Zartbitterschokolade, Zartbitterhohlkörper.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oder, wenn ihr sagt, ihr mögt gar kein Zartbitter,
dann nehmt weiß oder Vollmilch.
Also das, was ich vorgegeben habe, sind ja nur Ideen.
Ihr könnt ja praktisch die Füllung,
die eine Füllung in die anderen Hohlkörper reinstecken
und
– oh, jetzt bitte. Das war jetzt keine Vorlage für den Güni.
>> MURAT: Doch. Ich wollte gerade sagen...
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Du, ich habe auch mit Hohlkörpern zu tun,
aber auf der Baustelle.
Da muss ich jetzt auch gleich hin.
Der Güni wartet auf mich.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Alles klar.
>> MURAT: Das war ja eine Steilvorlage.
Du hast es auch gleich gemerkt, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ich habe es gleich gemerkt an deinem Gesicht.
>> MURAT: Ich habe es gleich gemerkt, ohne Witz.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Also ich wünsche euch jedenfalls
viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Seid kreativ!
Ich habe jetzt heute keine fruchtigen Pralinen gemacht.
Denn ich habe die letzten Jahre
schon einige fruchtigen gemacht.
Schaut also gern noch in meiner App vorbei,
auf dem Blog vorbei.
Ich habe echt schon viele Pralinenrezepte gemacht.
>> MURAT: Einfach "Sally Pralinen" eingeben.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Die Praline.
>> MURAT: Also...
>> SALLY: Also tobt euch einfach aus!
>> MURAT: Macht's gut! Macht's besser!
Und...
>> SALLY: Bis bald!
>> MURAT: Frohes Weihnachtsfest.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Kann ich die auf die Bau-
>> SALLY: Mit Salz-Erdnuss.
>> MURAT: Kann ich auf die Baustelle ein paar mitnehmen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: So vielleicht die Hälfte
und die andere Hälfte kannst du Ding geben
– deinen Eltern.
Nee, dann haben wir keine mehr.
Ich nehme die Hälfte mit und die andere Hälfte bleibt bei uns.
>> SALLY: Ich mache noch mal.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Bis dann.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Tschüss!
[Musik]